I don't like them putting chemicals in
the water that turn the freaking frogs
everyone laughed at Jones for this but
as it turns out it might be true in 2014
Canadian researchers added estrogen the
hormone found in birth control pills
into the water of fish and almost right
away the male fish literally started to
produce eggs in their testicles they
were being feminized the lead researcher
said and guess what this exact birth
control hormone is found in your water
why because a ton of women in the US are
on birth control they pee out that birth
control into the toilet and that
Wastewater gets sent to a water
treatment facility but since these
facilities don't have the capability to
filter out these hormones all that birth
control estrogen gets sent straight back
into your attack water that you drink
and bathe in and so that makes you
wonder right as humans who are drinking
tap water on a day in day out basis what
kind of impact does this have on our own
endocrine systems and one would think
that it's extremely estrogenic and
influences male behavior in a way that
probably isn't healthy